i think
it's a sort of if i can generalize
there's a sort of mix of
anxiety about climate change out of
control
technological progress out of control
and also the idea um
sometimes that society is sick as well
um and i think the thinking is that
science has
um you know i'm saying what i think what
i understand their understanding to be
because
as i as i as i alluded to before i don't
think we can blame science
it's just a way of asking questions but
i think they think that um
science has helped diagnose the problem
for example of climate change but hasn't
found any solutions and in order to find
solutions
we need to come together we need to um
almost be almost invoke
you know it's more of a kind of
religious spiritual discussion about
what who are we what is our role here
how must we act
um what is our relationship with the
with the other species on the planet
with the future with
with with nature um and what is our
responsibility towards it and those are
questions that i think they think that
science can't answer i think you know
climate change
you have a tension between what
individuals can do
and what political entities can can do
and there is this myth in my view
that you can in terms of climate change
that if every
every individual does is a little bit
you will you will sort out the problem
which most people would say is not
serious
because these the political structures
between you
and the planet they still matter a lot
uh and so depending on what china will
do and what the government of china will
do what the government of the united
states will do what the variety of
powers will do that will change a lot
and so there is a
kind of contradiction between this again
the empowerment of the individual
as the supreme king of the world and the
fact that in reality
he she is not uh and then the debate
gets further polluted
in my view by uh the promise of hell
uh in the in the 20s and 30s we were i
mean
humanity was promised paradise a radiant
future
and that shuts the debate uh now we are
promised hell
and that also shuts the debate because
if you
if you want a serious discussion on how
to deal with things
you have to discuss the pros and cons of
a variety of options
where the intermediate structures that
states are
will have to play a role and that does
not fit
in the in the sort of dominant mantra of
the great
toonberg of this world